it's been some time since I shot a video
in the philosophical development and
commitments series where I talk about
precisely that my own philosophical
commitments and my development going all
the way back to undergraduate and
sometimes even before that so I had a
correspondent and actually a student and
a friend of mine emailed me recently and
say hey Greg what is with all this stoic
stuff all of a sudden so I thought that
this might be a good occasion to start
adding some more videos to that series
and I'd start out by talking
specifically about stoic philosophy and
what you know my background in it is and
why I find it interesting and attractive
but I'm not really a stoic in a
traditional or Orthodox sense although I
do draw pretty heavily on stoicism so a
little bit of recap some time ago in
fact not even in this this new space but
back in our old apartment in Kingston I
shot a number of videos it looks like
there were about seven or eight where I
would talk about how I went through a
particular phase in in philosophy and
that you know there's quite a few more
stories to tell and that's week sequence
or about you know particular
philosophers or philosophical schools or
traditions that are still quite
important for me or which have assumed
some new and perhaps even additional
importance by comparison to the past so
stoicism fits into that that second
sphere I didn't go through anything like
a stoic phase like I went through an
Annie Jian phase or a Vidkun Stein phase
or actually I went through a dari die
phase and I'll do a video about that
some other time
instead stoicism has been something that
has been growing on me
over time so like I said I can't call
myself a stoic in any sort of strictly
traditional or Orthodox sense I'm okay
with people calling me neo stoic or a
modern stoic because there's there's
quite a bit of debate about those those
terms but it's probably better to view
me as something like a eclectic somebody
like Cicero for example who was was
quite attractive to stoicism and in some
of his works embraces it very closely
but who is not himself a stoic and tells
us that that he doesn't actually belong
to that school although you know
fortunately we know a lot about the
middle Stoics and the early Stoics
through his his works so I am an
eclectic that means that I you could say
I pick and choose that's what you know
eclectic comes from you know picking
things out but it's I always will try to
you know synthesize and harmonize these
things as well so you know I'm very
drawn to the stoic school I'm also very
drawn to you know certain plate inist
ideas the Aristotelian tradition which
includes even people like you know later
on like Thomas Aquinas I have a strong
interest in in certain Christian
thinkers like for instance monastic
writers like John Cassian all the way up
to Saint Anselm of Canterbury I also
have a strong interest in you know the
Hegelian / dialectical tradition on the
one hand and the existentialist whatever
we want to call it movement mishmash of
thinkers on the other hand and I have
some some interest as well in
psychoanalysis and in what we might call
modern political theory writ writ large
so that's a lot of stuff all mixed
together but stoicism is pretty
important to me and I use quite a bit of
stoic insights and practices in my
own day-to-day philosophical practice in
and working with clients I'll talk a
little bit more about that later on so
what I would like to start well I've
already started but what I would like to
move into next is talking about how I
got interested in stoicism at all or how
you know maybe it might be better to say
how I got to know some of the Stoics and
it happened in a set of waves or phases
so stoicism was not a philosophy that I
encountered prior to going to college
and some of you may know I didn't go to
college right away I I didn't intend to
go to college at all I graduated from
high school and you know kind of screwed
around a bit and you know worked in
restaurants and studied martial arts and
then I went and joined the army and I
was in the Army for a bit and I actually
picked up some some things about
philosophy while I was in the army
because I would buy books and talk with
people and then I got out and then I I
went to college and I declared a major
in philosophy immediately not actually
knowing what's getting into and in my
college studies I encountered two stoic
texts so I did get to do some firsthand
reading of the Stoics and it was Marcus
Aurelius meditations nice fairly short
book and Epictetus is and karidian a
much shorter book and that was all that
I knew about stoicism I read the
Epictetus in an ancient philosophy class
and I think I picked up the Marcus and
read it on my own and I read references
to the Stoics here and there but for the
most part they were not written by
people who I think were very receptive
to stoicism they may have known
something about it but they are
generally fairly dismissive of the stoic
viewpoint and quite frankly although I
was attracted to
some aspects of the stoic philosophy
like you know being self-reliant and not
letting things get to you and you know
seeing yourself as as kind of this you
know courageous you know stand against
the world kind of kind of figure which
is not really when it comes down to at a
very accurate depiction of stoicism
there were a lot of elements of it that
I just you know didn't understand at all
or didn't find attractive for myself all
this talk about virtue I couldn't really
place it but it didn't sound very
interesting to me the notion of
cosmopolitanism of a whole community of
people across the world that we would
all treat well and all that not not very
interesting to me at that age either not
that I wasn't interested in people from
different places but it was always as
sort of individuals or as types of
things not as a sort of broader
cosmopolitan viewpoint and I I don't
think that I mean I did a lot of work in
terms of disciplining my body and
thereby also disciplining my mind and
during hardship that sort of stuff
but I wasn't you know doing the sort of
stoic discipline that would lead to what
well you know what the Stoics call
happiness and and freedom and and I was
interested in other things back then
quite frankly I had a pretty hedonistic
lifestyle and a very honor centric
lifestyle that carried all the way
through into graduate school but it was
particularly so as a young man in
college and you know I was drinking
quite a bit and and you know having a
lot of fun and and so stoicism really
wasn't something I took seriously as
philosophy as a way of life I thought
well that's great for some people and
here's some interesting ideas and now I
know something about it and and I kind
of left it at that and then I you know
went to graduate school again I took a
break worked for a year there's a
you know video stuff about that I don't
need to rehearse that story and there I
learned more about stoicism then you
could say I started taking stoicism more
seriously in part because I saw that the
Stoics well not necessarily accepted or
endorsed sometimes they were actually
being attacked were taken very seriously
by some of the other philosophers who I
thought were were worth studying so you
know David Hume is a great example
Descartes of course who I you know
really enjoy reading has a neo stoic
ethic running throughout his work Blaise
Pascal thought that the Stoics were one
of the main rivals to his sort of you
know Christian philosophy that he was
developing in the policies you know
later thinkers as well like mock
Schaller for example will write about
you know the stoic ethos and in very
interesting ways and so you know I think
that helped me out a lot you know I have
a very sort of meandering path of
philosophical development which I'm not
suggesting as a model for anybody unless
it happens to work for you but I'll tell
you this that along the way it was in
large part by seeing other people who I
respected taking a philosopher or a text
or a tradition seriously that I got the
idea that well there's probably
something there that I need to study and
pay attention to it was either that or
picking something up by chance and
digging into and saying wow there's
really something going on here and there
was also an element of that in my
understand or my approach to stoicism
that took place in graduate school as
well and this centred around one book
which I happened to find in a used
bookstore now there was a place in on
the strip as we
that in carbondale and had a great used
bookstore and I don't remember the name
offhand but I used to go in there quite
frequently I would say it was probably
there once every two weeks or so looking
around particularly in the philosophy
section see if anybody had sold any
books that I wanted to pick up and I
happen to see a copy of Epictetus
discourses now I knew about the
enchiridion I didn't know about the
discourses and if you know anything
about stoic literature you know that the
enchiridion is very very short and the
discourses are quite long there's a lot
there's four books and each of those
books has a number of longest chapters
and the enchiridion is compiled out of
the discourses although we seem to have
lost some of the books so the
enchiridion is just a tiny tiny little
little selection out of what's contained
in the discourses now the discourses
themselves don't provide us with the
entirety of what
Epictetus talk because epictetus didn't
write anything down it's his disciple
areas who who wrote these things down
and like I said we've probably lost half
of the the books of the discourses but
what we've got is pretty incredible
stuff and it lays out at least the
outlines of a systematic stoic approach
to things and so I started reading this
and I was just fascinated in part
because when I was in graduate school I
became more and more interested in the
you know we call it the question of the
the will and I don't want to say that
epictetus actually has a full-blown
conception of the will prior ASUS is not
quite the same thing as the Faculty of
will or voluntas we're gonna see in
later authors but it's pretty close and
Epictetus gave me a lot of stuff to
think about how habit works how our
choices affect our
you know possibilities for future
choices whether the will is free or not
or whether the Faculty of choice if we
want to call it that is free or not in
what respect it's free what we can do
with our freedom all these really great
questions that were also being asked and
addressed by say you know for example
Christian thinkers in the Middle Ages or
by the existentialist in the modern age
or by Hegel in his philosophy or by
Plato and Aristotle so I saw Epictetus
at least as providing a really coherent
understanding of the human person not
one the yet that I could necessarily get
on board with there's there was a lot of
asceticism that I was you know found
kind of repellent there there's still
you know some things on which I disagree
with the Stoics which is one reason why
I can't consider myself an orthodox
stoic in any sense but well I was in
graduate school you can see there was
all this sort of you know
reappropriation of stoicism going on I
have to admit that I was much more you
know steering myself much more towards
the Aristotelian tradition on the one
hand and Christian thinkers and then you
know various continental strains you
know the Hegelian ISM the existentialist
thought phenomenology and psychoanalysis
you know but there was room in there for
for thinking about things along with the
Stoics and so I would keep going back I
really enjoyed reading and rereading
Epictetus discourses as a matter of fact
for a while it turned me off on reading
the enchiridion because I'd be like well
why would I want to read that what I've
got the discourse is that I can dig into
and I remember reading Marcus a few more
times while I was in graduate school
because it's not that long of a read
didn't read any anybody else other than
of course Cicero Cicero is is
I'm a huge fan of for many reasons I'll
probably do a video specifically about
Cicero and and why I'm attracted to his
writings and his his thought but I'll do
that at another time in any case the
upshot for stoicism is that when I'm
reading Cicero's texts I'm getting quite
a bit of stoicism you know either as
mentions or with a character who is
explicitly belonging to the stoic school
presenting the views and then oftentimes
being rebutted by another character in
the dialogues or by Cicero himself
partially endorsing the stoic viewpoint
on things so you know I got to know
quite a bit about stoicism and in
graduate school didn't write on it I was
working on other things at the time and
then I you know finished my dissertation
which I wrote on Maurice blow now didn't
really have anything to do with stoicism
started teaching at Indiana State Prison
and now I was teaching a wide range of
classes including intro to philosophy
nearly every semester and ancient
philosophy I got to teach and actually
students there were very interested in
the Stoics and this is about the time
that Tom Wolfe's a man in full came out
it was about a guy studying stoicism in
prison not the kind of prison that my
guys were in but so there was you know
quite a bit of going back and forth and
talking about the Stoics and and that
would that helped to keep it alive as
well at one time I was uh I had a
student who was interested in writing
about the enchiridion from the
perspective of a prisoner and we did
some you know back and forth working
notes but but it never really got
developed maybe that's a project for the
future sometime so after graduate school
I was you know teaching in the prison
and I was also working on my own
scholarly work in my office on my own
and you know going to conferences and
engaging in in
in ours and writing papers and all that
sort of stuff and I didn't write much on
the Stoics but I was very interested as
I still am in models of practical
rationality and I've always used the
Stoics as one of those examples I also
became more and more interested in the
let's call it the phenomenon of anger
and the relationship between that
emotion the other emotions human drives
and desires and the Faculty of reason
and how anger influences our choices how
it directs in certain respects our will
so I began reading what different
philosophical and literary and
theological and psychological traditions
had to say about anger and the Stoics
have a lot to say about that topic that
I found quite interesting I don't agree
with all of it you know for example the
Stoics think that anger is uniformly bad
and the Aristotelian czar sort of
they're big you know rivals and they
they say that and so I don't go all the
way along with the Stoics on that but I
do think that the Stoics developed a lot
of really useful techniques so if you if
you were an Aristotelian and thought
that anger could be sometimes good but
was often bad and it needed to be you
know the emotions needed to be trained
and all that you you couldn't you know
do do worse than to bring in a whole
bunch of stoic insights and ideas and
that is in fact what I do in anger
management when I'm working with clients
I actually bring together these these
perspectives so you know doing all this
research on anger and how it's been
understood over the ages and what works
and what doesn't work involved a lot of
study of the Stoics and that got me
reading you know one of the other
important stomachs who we still have the
works of and that's Seneca because
Seneca wrote a book on anger and it also
got me to learn what other people had to
say
they say about the Stoics which is part
of how we learn about about the stoic
tradition by reading Galen for example
or by reading Plutarch or some of these
other authors who were not Stoics and
we're sometimes quite critical of the
Stoics Cicero's you know another another
person that I read quite a bit and so
what was great about this is it led to
me having gradually developing a deeper
understanding of the history of ideas
and its development in in the West you
know through the development of Greek
philosophy and its importation into the
Roman Empire and then it's spread and
and how it continued influencing things
during the Dark Ages and the
reconstitution and the Middle Ages and
you know the High Middle Ages and then
into the Renaissance in the modern
period so you know I was interested in
stoicism not so much just in terms of
you know philosophy as a way of life the
way that a lot of people are interested
in it by the way the philosophy is a way
of life thing you know great that that
people like to read pure I know that was
never something that people weren't
practicing in the past I mean you know
it's not a rediscovery to know that that
philosophy was meant to be practical in
a way of like read some Hegel read some
Maurice blown-down read some Kierkegaard
read some you know read these other
people read a piano song who Otto you
know took quite a quite a bit from and
you'll realize that this is this is not
a radically new conception but in any
case you know I was I was very
interested in how the Stoics fit into
things and then I you know there was a
back-and-forth I would see okay this is
useful for this idea this is useful for
the anger that I'm trying to make sense
of and also struggling with and and you
know might want to write about sometime
and these these inter fused with each
other so that took me
to quite a long time I ended up writing
an article for the Catholic the new
Catholic Encyclopedia on stoicism which
was cool because I got to do some more
research and learn more about the early
and and middle Stoics some of which I
already knew but a lot of which I got to
you know do some more you know study
about and then in the last five years I
would say I've become more and more
interested part you know in a
particularly personal way and I think
for myself it probably took a maturation
process before I could completely
understand why stoic philosophy would in
fact have the attraction that it does
you know I'm somebody who took quite a
while to grow up you might say and I
found stoic insights very useful in you
know my philosophical counseling
practice working with clients I you know
sometimes don't tell them that the ideas
are coming from the Stoics but I used
quite a quite a bit of it particularly
from epictetus I have to say he's
probably my favorite of the Stoics and
as you probably know I I'm actually at
present the editor of stoicism today
which is an online magazine let's call
it devoted to you know ways in which
people are adapting stoicism to to the
modern age and the problems of life I'm
very honored to have that position and
it came about because I was doing more
and more writing and more and more video
work dealing with the Stoics I still
have yet to do much academic writing but
that's you know slow in coming but I
will eventually be writing some articles
on the Stoics
I'm working on several different book
projects more popularly oriented having
to do with with stoicism and it's it's
you know relevance and addict
a Shinto to various issues like anger
for example or what stoicism has to say
about leadership and I I think that it's
going to be something that I'm going to
keep on researching and deepening my
engagement with over the course of my
career which I'm hoping is only half
over
you know if I live to 80 or so and get
to work you know the entire time I'll
have a lot more interesting things about
the Stoics towards the end of that then
I then I perhaps do at present but and
I'll hopefully also know a little bit
more experiential about putting the
stuff into practice but it's a something
that I'm very interested in and I
present doesn't mean that I'm not
equally within the Aristotelian
tradition or other important traditions
that are components of my philosophical
commitments and developments but
stoicism is something that I think for
me is here to stay